افادت مراسله الجزيره بمقتل اسرائيليين
واصابه 14 اخرين جرعه في جارين وقع احدهما
قرب محطه للحافلات في القدس وقالت اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان احد الانفجارين وقع
نتيجه عبوه ناسفه زرعت في المكان واغلقت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه مداخل المدينه وبدات
حملات تفتيش بحثا عن منفذ العمليه
وتراس وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي فينيجانس
مشاورات الامنيه بمشاركه قاده الاجهزه
الامنيه بعد العمليه
والله
كونغ فو اذا ان هذه الصور مباشره تاتينا
من القدس فيما يبدو موقع العمليه حيث
مازالت تجري
عمليات البحث والتمشيط على 3 هذين
التفجيرين وسنعرف التفاصيل واخر الحصيله
من مراسله الجزيره نجوان السمري والتي
تبدو معنا جائزه نجوان مرحبا بك
[موسيقى]
نعم
قبل قليل اعلنت المصادر الطبيه
الاسرائيليه عن مقتل احد المصابين في
الانفجار الذي وقع صباح هذا اليوم بالقرب
من محطه حافلات عند المدخل الرئيسي لمدينه
القدس من الجهه
الغربيه كانت المصادر الطبيه قد اعلنت عن
مصابين بحاله حرجه احدهما تم الاعلان قبل
قليل عن مصرعه في هذه العمليه حصيله
الاصابات في هذا الانفجار خمسه عشره
بوضع حرج وهناك اصابتان بوضع خطير الى
جانب اصابات تتراوح بين المتوسطه
والخفيفه بعد هذا الانفجار الذي وقع عند
المدخل الرئيسي لمدينه القدس من الجهه
الغربيه
بعد قرابه نصف ساعه انفجار همم اخر في همم
محور طرق ومحطه للحافلات رئيسي اخر في
منطقه مستوطنه رمود همم
من هناك كانت اصابات طفيفه لثلاثه مصابين
تم نقلهم الى المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
حصيله الاصابات لهذين الانفجارين حتى هذه
اللحظه 14 اصابه وقتيل اذا 14 اصابه اجراء
الانفجارين في مدينه القدس قوات الشرطه
تنتشر بشكل كبير في ارجاء مدينه القدس في
الشطرين الغربي والشرقي وقد اعلنا قبل
قليل همم الضباط الشرطه عن رفع حاله
التاهب الى درجه قسوه في مدينه القدس
وعمليات بحث وتمشيط واس عن مشتبه او
مشتبهين بهم بتنفيذ هذه العمليه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تحاول حتى هذه اللحظه اللحظه
تحديد ما اذا كان اا منفذ العمليه هو ذاته
الذي قام بعمليه التفجير في الموقعين او
انه يدور الحديث عن خليه همم مشتركه قامت
بتنفيذ عمليه الانفجار بالتزامن في
منطقتين مختلفتين في مدينه القدس او انها
عمليه مزدوجه نفذها شخص واحد حتى هذه
اللحظه تقوم الشرطه الاسرائيليه بجمع
كاميرات المراقبه من هذه المناطق التي حدث
فيها التفجيرات كما تشاهدون نحن منذ قرابه
الساعه نحاول الوصول الى موقع التفجير
الاول لكن هناك ازمات مروريه خانقه اغلاق
عدد كبير من الشوارع في مدينه القدس تم
اغلاق المنطقه بالكامل التي وقع بها
التفجير عند المدخل الرئيسي
للقدس من الجهه الغربيه وكذلك تم اغلاق
مقطع
عفوا مقطع رئيسي في شارع يعتبر همم احد
اكبر الشوارع الرئيسيه الفاصل او الواصل
بين مدينتي تل ابيب والقط شارع رقم واحد
ازمات همم مروريه خانقه قوات كبيره للشرطه
الاسرائيليه تنتشر في مدينه القدس في
محاوله
لعمليات بحث وتمشيط والامساك بمن قام
بتنفيذ هذه الانفجارات هناك حاله من
الصدمه على المستوى السياسي وعلى المستوى
همم في الشارع الاسرائيلي من هذه العمليه
اوصف بانها منعطف خطير في مسار التصعيد
الحاصل في فلسطين في الاراضي